اصدرت لجنه الطاعه في الكنيست قرارا يقضي
بابعاد النائب احمد الطيبي عن الكنيست مده
اسبوعين بسبب مواقفه من الحرب ومن تصريحات
نواب من اليمين المتطرف بشان الحرب وتهجير
سكان غزه ينضم الينا من القدس الدكتور
احمد الطيبي عضو الكنيست الاسرائيلي مرحبا
بك سيد
احمد ما الذي جرى بالضبط اخبرنا عن هذا
الموضوع
يعني على
مدى الاسابيع الاخيره ومنذ بدء هذا
العدوان
وهذ الحرب كان لنا مواقف واضحه
شامخه صريحه ضد الحرب وضد العدوان وضد
القتل الجماعي وخاصه نشبت
مواجهات
قويه حاميه الوطيس احيانا مع اولئك الذين
مثلا
نادوا بضرب غزه
بالنووي من وزراء
ونواب في ائتلف واولئك الذين قالوا لا
يوجد ابرياء في غزه او امحو غزه هذا تطلب
منا موقفا واضحا وفعلا تصدينا لهؤلاء وكان
موقفنا وموقف الكتله التي امثلها الجبهه
العربيه للتغيير منذ البدايه ضد هذه الحرب
بلا تردد
اي هذا ادى في نهايه المطاف الى تقديم
عشرات
الشكاوي ضدي من قبل نواب اليمين ونواب
المعارضه ايضا على فكره اكبر عدد من
الشكاوي
ضد النواب العرب وصلت من حزب يش عتيد اللي
هو في المعارضه واضافه الى جمعيات يمينيه
متطرفه وبعض نواب الائتلاف قررت اليوم
لجنه الطاعه ابعادي لمده اسبوعين عن
القاعه العامه وعدم اعطائ حق الكلام منعي
من الكلام منعي من عرض موقفي اللي هو
بسببه لحق بهذا
العقاب اخي العزيز هذا الموقف لا يمكن ان
يتغير مع عقاب بدون عقاب مع ابعاد بدون
دون ابعاد لا يمكن الا ان يكون هكذا وا
موقفنا جميعا انا
وزملائي في الكتله سيبقى موقفا شامخا
واضحا وصريحا ضد القتل الجماعي وضد جرائم
الح الذي قدمت بحقه هذه
الشكاوى لا قدمت بحق كثيرين قبل
اي شهر ونصف ايضا زميله لي عيده توما
سليمان
ابعدت من ال القاعه ونواب اخرين نائبه
ايان خطيب ولكن ما من شك في انه اي احن
كنا متوقعين انه هم غير قادرين على سماع
صوت مغاير للاجماع الداعم للحرب حتى عندما
كنا ايه نقول اطفال غزه مجرد ذكرنا لتعبير
اطفال غزه او تعاطفنا مع اطفال غزه او
القول انه كل طفل هو طفل ولا يوجد طفل
افضل من طفل اخر كانوا يبدا بالصراخ
والانقضاض وتقديم الشكاوى انه هذا دعم
للارهاب ودعم لحماس ودعم لمنظمات
ارهابيه وخاصه عندما كنا نذكر اعداد
الاطفال الفلسطينيين الذين ارتقوا
شهداء والمدنيين بشكل عام والمنشات الطبيه
يعني اي
وخاصه اليوم مثلا في هناك لجنه تبحث ابعاد
زميلي عوفر
كسيف من الكنيست عامه القدره على تحمل
الراي الاخر وخاصه في فترات
الحرب
لدى الكنيست واعضائها وزرائها ونوابها شبه
معدومه هذا الاجراء لجمهور العربي في
البلاد واعتقالات كانت بالمئات مجرد ابداء
راي او كتابه ايه او بوست او ستاتوس اي
ولكن نحن اقوى من هذا المنع
اي لم لم تطل او لم يطل هذا الاجراء الا
نواب عرب
صحيح
ايه الابعاد من الكنيست نعم في الماضي
ايضا تم ابعاد نائب واحد تحدث عن ضروره
حرق الاطفال ابعد ل اسبوعين نحن نعتقد ان
موقف من هذا يستدعي ابعاد لاشهر مش
لاسبوعين اي انا تصديت لنائبه قالت يجب
ارسال صواريخ اريحه اللي فيها رؤوس
نوويه على غزه ولوزير عم حايل الياهو اي
بالاضافه للنائبه جتلف اياها اللي قال يجب
استعمال النووي ضد غزه وكان السجال حاميا
وطيس
اي لا نستبعد ان يستمروا في هذه الشكاوى
ولكن بموازاه ذلك نحن نتلقى سيل من
التهديدات النواب العرب وانا شخصيا
تهديدات بالقتل لمجرد طرحنا هذه المواقف
واتهام بدعم الارهاب
واعداء عشرات رسائل التهديد بالقتل التي
تصلنا وتصل الزملاء العرب طيب ماذا يترتب
عاده على هذا الاجراء الطرد او الطرد من
القاعه او الابعاد عن الكنيست لمده
اسبوعين اولا منعنا من الكلام في القاعه
العامه يعني الخطابات اللي تعودتم علينا
بها في كل هذه الفتره سنمنع عنها اسبوعين
النقطه الثانيه سنع من حقي في تقديم
قوانين مثلا هذا الاسبوع كان يجب ان اتقدم
بقانون اللي يقر يمنع من
ذلك
و في اللجان في اللجان
يسمح الدخول ولكن القاعه العامه ممنوع
الحديث فيها وموضوع القاء الموقف والخ
سمعتك قلت بان احد النواب الان يتم بحث
منعه بالكامل يعني طرده من كنيست يعني سحب
نيابته صحيح نعم النائب عفر كثيف من
كتلتنا ونائب يهودي
يساري وقع على عريضه
اي
لمثقفين ويساريين
اسرائيليين تؤيد التوجه
اي
لمحكمه لاهاي ووقف الحرب وقد قال انا
يهمني وقف الحرب لانه هو جزء من كتلتنا
كتلتنا كانت الوحيده انذاك التي قالت انه
يجب انهاء هذه الحرب فورا وعلى هذا قدم
اليوم بدات الجلسه اي وغدا سيتم
التصويت على ذلك بنهايه المطاف عوفر كسيب
سيبقى عضو في الكنيست ولكن هذه الاجراءات
لابعاده والتصويت عليه ستصل الى المحكمه
العليا والمحكمه العليا غالبا ستعيده ولكن
الاحزاب
الاسرائيليه بدات حملاتها الانتخابيه وعلى
راس بنيامين نتنياهو وكذلك الليكود وكذلك
حزب اسرائيل بيتنا وكذلك حزب عتيد
ولذلك يعتقدون انه الانقضاض على النواب
العرب وبتواضع عليه قد يساهم في رفع
اسهمهم امام جمهورهم امام
اليمين
المتطرف نعم العمل بدا حتى خلال
هذه لد الاحزاب الاسرائ احمد الطيبي عضو
الكنيست الاسرائيليه حدثنا من القدس